اهلا بكم من جديد الجهود الدوليه تتواصلوا
لايجاد حل وتسويه للازمه في السودان
الازمه التي تتصاعد مع تعنت طرفي الصراع
من الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
واسرارهم على الاقتتال والمواجهه المسلحه
عوضا عن احلال السلام وانهاء الازمه هذا
التصعيد جر السودان الى دوامه العقوبات
مجددا حيث اعلنت الخارجيه البريطانيه فرض
الحكومه عقوبات تتضمن تجميل اصول ضد 6
شركات دفاع تقدم مساعدات عسكريه لطرفي
النزاع في السودان كما كشف مصدر من
الخارجيه الامريكيه لصحيفه الشرق الاوسط
عن استعداد الولايات المتحده لاتخاذ خطوات
اضافيه في اطار فرض العقوبات وان واشنطن
ما زالت تعمل مع الاتحاد الافريقي والامم
المتحده ومنظمه ايجاد وشركاء المحليين
منهم الدوليين لحرفي النزاع على التوصل
الى اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار وحمايه
المدنيين والسماح بوصول المساعدات
الانسانيه
معنى من القاهره سيبويه يوسف الكاتب
الصحفي السوداني اهلا بك من القاهره ايضا
بكر ابراهيم الخبير العسكري واللواء
السابق في القوات الجويه السودانيه اهلا
بك معنا كذلك لواء معك مباشره يعني هل
يجب ان نعترف بانه كل محاولات الداخل
والخارج باءت بالفشل ولا امل في كل
المؤتمرات التي تنعقد حاليا خاصه مع الغضب
الحكومي والعسكري الرسمي السوداني من
الايجاد مؤخرا
نعم السلام لك
ولشاهدينك انا اعتقد ان العالم الخارجي
الذي أجج هذه الحرب
الان ادرك تماما ان الحرب كوسيله للوصول
لمستهدفات الغرب هذه الوسيله قد نفذت
اغراضها ولم يعد لها
لم يعد لها اي
حافز لديهم لكي تقوم الحرب
بتنفيذ مخططاتهم لذلك الاونه الاخيره
لجاوا للملف
الدبلوماسي الخارجي الاول ملف هو ملف اديس
ابابا نعلم ان هذا الملف قد احدث
فشل زريع لذلك انا انا اطلب من
مع الدول يعني ان يغير سياسه العصا عن
طريق
الحروب عن طريق
الجزاءات انا العقوبات المشكله بالضبط
الحكومي الرسمي من
كينيا ومن اثيوبيا ولكن طيب ماذا عن
المحاولات الاخرى طيب المحاوله المصريه
المحاوله السعوديه الامريكيه كل المحاولات
حتى الان لم تصل الى النتائج اللازمه بسبب
ما يصفه البعض بتعلم الطرفي النزاع
سناتي الى المحاوله المصريه لكن المحاوله
الانجليزيه التي اشرتم اليها والمحاولات
الامريكيه انا اقول انه قبل ربع
قبل ربع قرن من الان بدات هذه المحاولات
محاولات الحرب
العسكريه والحصار العسكري وهو الان بعد
هذا الحصار لمده 25 عام كان السودان في
ذلك الوقت يستجد طلقه ويستدي استعمل
الطلقه الان
معركه الكرامه في الخرطوم قد خاضها الجيش
السوداني
وتمانين في المئه من هذه المعدات تم
انتاجها داخل السودان نتيجه للحصار
لضيق الوقت
نعم ان
الدعم السريع ومن وراء الحريه والتغيير هي
ادوات من ادوات
الخارج للسيطره على المركز في الخرطوم انا
اقول ان الاجدر بهذه القوه نحن نحن نعترف
انها امريكا والدول العظمى لديها مصالح في
افريقيا في غلبه افريقيا وان في السودان
كل احتياطي اليورانيوم يوجد في السودان
وكل احتياطي
الحديث يوجد في دارفور وكذلك الزهق طيب مع
انه عقوبات البريطانيه اليوم يعني على
الطرفين وبالتساوي ثلاث شركات تدعم دعم
سريع وثلاثه شركات تدعم الجيش خليني
ارجعلك بعد شوي
نعطي الوقت للجميع استاذ سيبويه ما ردك
على هذا الكلام
في تقديره ان هذه الحرب هي حرب مفروضه
سواء على قوات الدعم السريع او على قوات
الجيش
وما يحدث الان من تعنت هو تعنت من طرف
واحد ومعلوم وهو الذي يسعى لافشال كل
المبادرات لافشال كل التحركات
الدول الاقليم الداعمه لوحده وتماسك
السودان
وحتى ما يتحدث عنه الخبير بابكر هو في
النهايه رؤيه يعني تجسد يعني
الدعاوي التي تتحدث عن نعم للحرب ورفض كل
المبادرات واتخاذ الطريقه الواحد طريقه
الصراع الذي بامتداداته سوف ينبد الى
الاقليم ونحن نعلم بان السودان محاط بدول
يعني الطبيعه حشه بس ليش عم نحكي عن تعنت
بهذا المجال وانت تعرف بانه بيان ابي احمد
اعتبر بانه هناك فراغ في قياده الدوله في
السودان وهذا اعتبرته السودان عدم اعتراف
بقياده الدوله الحاليه
ودعا لفرد حظر جوي ونزع المدفعيه الثقيله
خلافا للتفاهمات سابقه على ما يبدو
عندما نتحدث عن ما ذكره ابي احمد او
الموقف هو ذا يعتبر موقف
الايجاد
لنا الاجالات تتعامل مع الازمه السودانيه
بطرفي نزاع يعني هما اساسا مكون عسكري
واحد عبر وثيقه دستوريه الجيش يقوي الطرف
ودعم السريع يكون الطرف
وضوية والان عندما يتحدث عن ما بيتحدث عن
الحكومه السودانيه بتكلموا عن جيش جزء من
التركيبه بتاعه الوثيقه الدستوريه
وهذا هو التعبير باعتبار انا ليس هنالك
حكومه حقيقيه لان اذا رجعنا للوراء انه
الحكومه قبل يوم 24 اكتوبر اللي هي
الحكومه الانتقاليه بقياده عبد الله حمدو
واعتقد ان هذه الاشاره واضحه من خلال
القراءه الحقيقيه
لصدر من بيان الايجار
سياده اللواء
اولا
الممثل امينه العام للامم المتحده فوكر
اليوم ان الحكومه الحكومه السودانيه رفضت
قبوله
ممثل للامم المتحده هذا اغرار من الامم
المتحده ان هنالك حكومه في السودان وانها
رفضت ممثله الامم المتحده وان الامم
المتحده اسعنت لطلب الحكومه السودانيه
الان خارج الخرطوم لا يستطيع ان يدخل
الخرطوم اما من ناحيه
الحرب ودواعيها نحن نغيرون نحترف في
السودان ودول الجوار ان افريقيا او
افريقيا وسط افريقيا بالذات هي اداء
لتحسين الاقتصاد
العالمي في المستقبل وان العالم هو
بالعالم مجاعه وانها وسط افريقيا هو الحل
لكن لا نغر تلك
الادوات التي يستخدموها
الحروبات الداخليه
الحرب الدبلوماسيه هذه جربت قبل ربع قرن
وخرج بها السودان منتصرا عسكريا
حيث انه اصبح اصبح يصنع 80% من سلاحه وان
قوه الجيش السوداني ظهرت في حرب الكرامه
انتهت الى
سنتابع في هذا الموضوع تباعا شكرا جزيلا
لك سياده اللواء ابو بكر ابراهيم الخبير
العسكري ولواء السابق في القوات الجويه
السودانيه شكرا للاستاذ سيباوي يوسف
الكاتب الصحفي السوداني من القاهره كلاكما
تحياتي اليكما واليكم ايضا متابعينا
الكرام اينما كنتم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات